the title of the talk is get to know
apache kafka with jupiter notebooks like
i'm gonna love it there are so many good
jupiter jupiter notebook talks that are
happening and yeah i was one of the apps
so i was basically leading the program
committee for this year and yeah i love
jupiter logs so yeah francesco over to
you and can you please just uh
start with a short bio um
okay
thank you very much for the introduction
and
as
sunket says i'm francesca tisiot a
developer advocate at ivan
and ah pretty proud italian you will
know about this and you will get a sense
of this a little bit later in the talk
i'm really happy here today to share
together with my company ivan
how you start you can start your journey
into apache kafka with jupiter notebooks
just to mention about ivan we do open
source data platforms as many services
on top of the cloud of your choice and
we will see a little bit
of it later but back to the main topic
i like to start my talks
explaining why you should be here
and let's start with
why jupiter notebooks why are those
interesting
well if you want to learn
something new
usually you find
all the resources
in different ways you find documentation
somewhere piece of code somewhere else
the images all the content in another
piece and you have to juggle between
different places
on the other side jupyter notebooks are
amazing because within the same
kind of browser window you get
markdown text
images and also
executable code that you can run
even more with jupiter notebooks you
have the ability
to for example
take one of the windows and put it on
the side so if you have application that
requires you to check a couple of things
at the same time while you can do that
easily still staying in just one screen
okay i believe now i sold you about the
june peter notebooks part
of the talk let's talk about pachikafka
why should you care about kafka
well you know we are here at pi data and
i mean you will be in kind of a couple
of
positions either you just invented a new
idea and you are coding that in the new
shiny app that you just
created
or you somehow inherited an old app and
you have to maybe support it maybe
evolve it or maybe take it to the new
world
no matter if the app is new or old i
actually never saw an application
working in complete isolation
you have components within this app that
needs to talk with each other or you are
exposing this app out to the world and
you will have this app talking with
another application
let me tell you a secret kafka it's a
tool that makes this communication easy
fast and reliable
so
in order to understand why we need to go
to kafka let's understand also what we
did in the past
in the past if we had an application
most of the times this application was
writing data reading data from a backend
database
however
this kind of write and read wasn't
performed for every each record the
application was batching a group of
records and pushing them in the database
or reading
the records from the database in batches
this meant that there was a consistent
delay from when the information was
generated in the application and when it
was landing in the database
or when the information was available in
the database and when it was landing in
the application
now we live in a fast word where we
don't have the luxury of this kind of
waiting time we need to build
event-driven applications which are
event that as soon as an event
is generated in the real life they will
want to know about it start parsing it
and probably taking the output of their
parsing and push it to another
application which will be another event
driven application
creating a chain of those
so we need to create those kind of
application but really what is an event
and i believe you all know what an event
is we have been knowing events since
long time and for example we have been
knowing events as notification
someone sent us a message we receive a
notification we make a payment with our
credit card we receive a notification
someone else tall steals our credit card
and makes a payment we need to receive a
notification immediately we cannot wait
two hours we want to receive immediately
and we ourself act as an event-driven
application in order to go and block the
credit card
going into the mobile world in this time
of pandemic we all have been using
mobile phones in order to create a food
order to order some food so by the time
that we open the phone we select the
restaurant we select which pizzas we
want we are creating a chain of events
and
once we create the order the pizzeria
will act as an event-driven application
and create a pizza and a certain point
we will receive the notification that
the pizza is ready
big win
so
why event driven is necessary it's
necessary because in this fast word
the value of an information sometimes is
strictly related to the time that it
takes to be delivered
if we think for example the example of
the position of the delivery person
taking our pizza to us
we can accept the delay between when the
position is taken from the delivery
person to the timing that it goes into
our mobile of 10 seconds
if the delay is 5 minutes the position
information is useless
so what is kafka kafka as i said there's
something that makes this communication
easy reliable and fast
the basic of kafka is just a lock a log
where we write one event after the other
the log is an append only immutable data
structure so that means that we can
write one event after the other and once
we have write event number zero in the
log it's there it's not like a record in
a database that we can go there and
change
if something changes the reality of the
event number zero for us it will be a
new event in the lock
and of course kafka can handle multiple
events of multiple logs of multiple
event type and in kafka terms those logs
are called topic
so why kafka makes this communication
reliable because it's a distributed
system so when you create a kafka
instance you are actually creating a
cluster of nodes
which in kafka terms are called brokers
now our log information is stored across
the cluster but not just one time
installed multiple times
following a configuration parameter
called replication factor in our example
we have three copies of the sharp pages
log and replication factor is three
and two copies of the round edges log
replication factor of two
why do we do that well because we know
that computers are not entirely reliable
so we could lose a node but still we are
not going to lose any information
this makes kafka highly available and
fall tolerant
now that we understood the beauty of
kafka the basics of kaka it's time to
understand
what kafka thinks that
an event is
and
kafka has a pretty back approach in
order to define an event for all that
matters to kafka an event is just a key
value pair
and we can use pretty simple
event description like temperature marks
as key and 35.3 as value or we could go
wild and going back to the pizza example
we could use
the shop receiving the pizza order
together with the phone line used to
make the order as key
and the order id the name of the person
making the order and the list of pizzas
as value
we can use json like in this case or we
can use other formats kafka really
doesn't unders it doesn't care for kafka
it's just a series of bytes
now let's understand how we can write to
kafka
we have our python application that
wants to write to kafka so it's called a
producer
and writes to a topic
all the producer needs to know in order
to write to a topic is where to find
kafka host name and port how to
authenticate and how to encode the
information that
in the source application may be in json
format into the row series of bytes that
kafka understands
on the other side we have a topic and we
have an application that wants to read
from it that is called the consumer
what the consumer does is it treats
event number zero and communicates back
to kafka zero down let's move the offset
to one
risk number one communicates back to
kafka one is done let's move to two
why communicating the offset back to
kafka is useful
well because again we know that
computers are not entirely reliable our
consumer could crash
the next time that we reinstate the
consumer we don't want to restart
reading the log from the beginning but
since kafka knows until what point in
the log the previous version of the
consumer was reading it will be able to
send us the next item in the list the
item number three
in order to read from kafka
all the consumer has to know is again
where to find kafka how to authenticate
since before we were encoding the data
now we need to decode it and last which
is the topic name of topic names because
i could read from more than one topic
that i want to start reading from
now this is a lot of theory i believe
you are like me you like to know jupiter
notebooks kafka so let's go into a nice
demo
let me show you what i built for you so
as again i'm italian so we will talk a
lot about pizzas before doing that let's
cover the basics i created for you a
kafka pi data instance on ivan on ivan
as i said we offer open source data
platforms as managed services you can
create not only kafka but also other
things like postgres my sql
elasticsearch
i created for you just 40 minutes ago a
kakapo data instance
now let's go into the jupiter notebooks
there will be the url of the jupyter
notebooks at the end of the session if
you want to try it yourself
let's open the producer
so what we will do here is first of all
install the kafka python library which
is the basic library allowing us to
interact with kafka
second we create a producer all the
producer has to know is where to find
kafka first name and port how to
authenticate in this case i'm using ssl
and how to encode the information
from json to row series of byte in ascii
okay the producer is created let's try
to send our first message
i'm sending a nice pizza order from
francesco myself ordering a pizza
margherita my favorite one
okay
the code is executed so the message is
in kafka
how can we be sure that the message is
in kafka well first of all we flash the
message this should ensure that the
message in kafka but if we want to check
we can create a consumer and as i was
showing you before you can pull the
consumer alongside the producer in order
to have them both
visible at the same time
so we can instantiate a consumer
and we are pointing to the same most
import using the same
authentication and this time we add the
coding
we can check which topics are available
in kafka and we see a list of internal
topics together with a nice pizza orders
which is the topic that i created when i
inserted the first record
i can subscribe to it
and then i can start my consuming thread
we can immediately notice a couple of
things the first one is
that this thread never ends
and we are kind of expecting it because
as i said we are in a event-driven kind
of world so we want our consumer to be
there ready to receive new messages new
events coming from kafka so we expect
that this threat will never end
on the other side there is an
interesting thing we submitted an order
for francesco of during a pizza
margarita but we don't see that printed
on our consumer side
well this is because by default when a
consumer attaches to kafka
it starts reading from the point in time
that it attaches to kafka
since we produce the
order first and then we attach the
consumer the consumer is not going back
in history will not be able to read that
message
this is the default setting and you can
change it
but just
be aware that if you create a
consumer with the default settings it
doesn't go back in history
in order to show you that the pipeline
is working let me create another couple
of orders the first one an order from
adelaide or during a pizza y
it's pizza y in italian it's the pizza
with pineapple on top
it's forbidden by low
i'm sad about it but you know that's the
reality
we also have another order for mark
pizza with chocolate this is barely
legal
let's produce the two events
and boom immediately we have them on the
consumer side so we have the first adele
y the second mark with chocolate
our pipeline producer kafka consumer
it's working
what should we do next
let's go to a little bit more slides
okay
let's talk about the log size now
one of the things that i told you before
is that
the log was contained the topic was
contained in one of the notes
but it would be said if
we had to somehow limit the amount of
data that we want to store in a log
because we have a limited amount of disk
space in one of our nodes
or the opposite if we have to purchase
gigantic
disk size because we want to store a
good amount of data
this is kind of a hard trade-off
but you know
kafka doesn't force this trade-off on us
allows us to have an extra degree of
freedom allowing us to use what are
called topic partitions
partition is a logical way of splitting
events belonging to the same topic into
subtopics called partitions
so going back to my pizza order example
i could partition my data into different
partitions based on for example the
the restaurant name so i could have the
francesco pizza orders in the blue
partition the luigi pizza orders in the
yellow partition and the mario's pizza
orders in the red partition
now if
we go back to our three node cluster
what is stored on the nodes
it's the partition it's not the wall log
this means that if we want to store
more data
in
in the same kind of disk space we just
need more partitions or optionally more
nodes there will be always a solution to
store more data if we need to
again here
if we lose a node in our cluster we will
not lose any data all the blue yellow
and red partitions data are still there
now
how do you select a partition
well usually the partition selection
is done with the key what kafka does it
hashes the key
and ensures that messages having the
same key end up in the same partition
you could also have the key as
null value not set in the key and in
that case you will never more or less be
sure to which partition you are sending
your data to
but why
selecting a partition is
something that you should care about
well
because
of ordering let me show you a little
example you have your producer that
writes to a topic with two partitions
and then you have your consumer
the in this example just three messages
that you are willing to to send a blue
one first a yellow one second and the
red one third
now when sending those three messages
the blue message will land in partition
zero
the yellow message will land in
partition one
and the red message will land in
partition 0 again
now when reading
from kafka it could happen could not
always be the case but it could happen
that you will read the messages with
this sequence
blue message first
red message second
and yellow message third
if you check the sequence of messages at
the start and at the end of our journey
the sequence is different
why is that well because if we start
using partitions we have to give up on
global ordering because kafka ensures
the correct ordering only per partition
so you need to think about your data set
and for which
subset of your data set you care about
the related order
in our pixel example it's good that we
use the the restaurant name as partition
key
because we care about if the order of
table a and table b for the same
restaurant which one comes first but we
don't really care if the order for
mario's pizza
comes before later for of an order for
luigi's pizza they are kind of unrelated
events
so we understood that partitions are
good because allow us to have a better
trade-off between disk size and load
size but partitions are bad because we
need to give up on global ordering
the other bit that makes partition good
is because they allow us to scale out
if you think about a topic
you can pretty much
tell that is just one thread writing one
event after the other
if now we have
three partitions
we can more or less imagine that we have
three events three processes that are
independent that can write events so we
can more or less
think that the throughput could be three
times faster we could have many more
producers
writing data to kafka and we can also
have
many more consumers reading data from
kafka
still you want to have those consumers
reading
all the data set from the topic
but probably
those
consumers don't want to read the same
event twice
how kafka handles it is that it assigns
to each consumer a non-overlapping
subset of partitions
if this last sentence didn't make
it clear
let me show you in these examples we
have three partitions and two consumer
what kafka will do it will assign the
blue partition to consumer one and the
yellow and red partition to consumer two
ensuring that all the messages no matter
which partitions are read by a consumer
and none of the message here is read
twice
after all there's a game theory it's
time to a partition for a partition's
demo
let me go back to my notebooks
and what i will do here is i will create
a new producer
i need a new producer the settings are
the same
what i will create now is i will
interact with kafka admin client which
allows you to interact at that mean
level with kafka and we'll create a new
topic
and the interesting way is this one i
will create a new topic with two
partitions
the topic is created
now i'm going to send a couple of
messages but before sending them
let's create a couple of consumers
let me create consumer one
and
i'm
creating the consumer
and let me create also another consumer
at the bottom
the code is exactly the same
so if
what i told you until now was true
what i'm saying here is a couple of
messages
one with key ed0 one with key d1
what kafka should do is should hash the
key and since those keys are different
one message should blood in should land
in one partition and the second message
should land in the second partition
since i have couple of consumer what
should happen in the consumer side is
that one consumer should read
one partition and one the other consumer
should read the other partition so it
should receive one message at the top
consumer and one message at the bottom
let's check it out
let's send a couple of messages and as
expected
at the top consumer i'm reading from
partition zero offset zero so the first
message of partition zero
the order from frank ordering the pizza
margarita that was the top one
the second consumer is reading from
partition one offset zero first message
of partition one the order from
madeleine with the pizza y
if now i send another couple of messages
here reusing the same keys as before
i should expect that mark the order for
mark of pizza with banana not something
that is i will suggest should land in
the same partition
as the um message as the order from
frank ordering the pizza margarita
because they share the same key
equal to zero and the same for jan
and adela
let's check this out
and exactly as expected mark is in the
same partition as frank and yang has the
same partition as the data
so i didn't lie to you
even for the partitions all working as
expected
let's go back to
a couple of more slides
one of the main differentiator of apache
kafka amongst the other messaging
systems is that
when a consumer reads a message from
kafka
kafka doesn't delete the message itself
making it available also for other
applications
to read it
in our case so far we had
our kafka topic with three partitions
and we had a couple of consumers those
consumers let's say that they were our
pizza makers they want to receive
uh every single pizza order
but they don't want to re read the same
pizza order twice they don't want to
make the same pizza twice
on the other side i could have the
billing person
that wants to read
a copy of each order
but wants to read at his own pace that
has nothing to do with the pizza makers
and doesn't want to read
the pizza orders
what doesn't want to fight against the
pizza makers to read those orders
how do i handle this with kafka well
kafka has the nice concept of consumer
groups
i just need to tell kafka look that my
two pizza makers belong to the same
consumer group and kafka will treat
those two consumers as part of a unique
application we'll share the load
of
the part of the messages across the
those two consumers
on the other side i could have my
billing person
and i just need to declare this new
consumer this new billing person
consumer as part of a new consumer group
and what kafka will do as well send a
separate copy of all the messages
belonging to that topic to the new
consumer
it will keep different offsets for the
different consumer groups in order to be
sure to understand until what point in
the topic that consumer group was
reading the data
as you can see here it can handle
multiple applications reading the same
topic in concurrent mode
or standalone mode
i will not show you a demo of this but
in the notebooks that i will link later
you will find examples also of this
multiple application
the last bit that i want to talk to you
about is kafka connect
[Music]
so far we have been writing code in
order to push data to kafka
and to read data from kafka
but this is not always the case
sometimes we want to integrate kafka
within an existing tech ecosystem we
have data in a database and we want to
push it to kafka
we don't want to write that code
ourselves we want to use a framework
that allows us to just say where the
data is
and when we want it to go
and this tool this framework should do
the job and this framework is kafka
connect
that is distributed scalable at kafka
and allow us to just say i want to take
the data from this postgres table from
this cassandra table from google pub sub
and automatically moves it to a kafka
topic
also if the data is in a kafka topic
we can reuse kafka connect
in order to sync the data to for example
postgres to any jdbc database to
bigquery because our analytics team
loves that in order to do analytics to
amazon is free for long term storage
kafka connect allows us to move data and
also change the shape a little bit i
want to close my talk with
some references
the first one is
my twitter handle
you can
interact with with me on twitter i'm
always open for questions for suggestion
if you like my jupiter notebooks example
please let me know if you don't like
them please let me know so i can improve
them
second
option
a second link sorry
this is the link for your notebooks the
notebooks that i've been showing you
today and a lot more that you can use to
play with other things that are
available in kafka
third link
if you want to start with kafka it's
it's an amazing platform but it's a
streaming platform in order to
understand the beauty of kafka you need
to have a streaming data source a
continuous flow of data
and it's not really simple to find such
a source of data in our real world
i created a fake data producer for kafka
and you can use it if you wish can
create fake pizza orders but also fake
metrics fake stock data and even using
the yahoo finance api real
stock information
the last bit is if you want to try kafka
but you don't have kafka
well you could take some time to install
a maternity yourself or you could use
our services ivan.tayo
we provided as many services and we have
also our 30 days 300
free trial that you can use in order to
know our services and please let us know
what you think about it
i hope this session was useful for you
and you took
some interesting information out of it
regarding you know python kafka or even
pizza i'm here for all the questions
that you may have
thank you very much
that was a great presentation uh i
you know i really loved it the reference
is the way of
just delivering it and everything
so yeah
yeah
uh you know i i so we all attendees and
we're chatting in the
chat box like you know we were getting
hungry when you were mentioning about
pizzas and stuff
that's the case the kind of this
presentation like i i like to
take the technology word into the stuff
that everybody loves
and also to stuff that creates a lot of
uh
debate and i found this pineapple pizza
is one of the key things that either you
are on a side or in the other
if i don't want my
italian citizenship to be revoked i need
to be on the defense side i cannot allow
pineapple piece but again it's your
choice
yeah
yeah awesome
so yeah we have a question for you and
the question is from ignacio and it goes
like what about creating fake messages
and pointers to the real messages to
keep track of the order
uh sorry can you repeat the question
yeah
what about creating fake messages with
pointers to the real messages to keep
track of the order so what you are so
one of the things about kafka is that
it's good it's beautiful to submit data
but you cannot for example
send entire files through kafka because
it's meant to have a small payload in
the uh in the message itself
if i understand well the question is
basically you are sending for example a
message with the file id and the file id
points to a file that is stored in an
amazon s3 bucket this is a common
pattern in kafka that allows you to
still make use of the event-driven
architecture but still don't have to
push files through kafka that could be a
painful way of using the tool
so i i got a message from massimo that
is asking what is what if an order is
cancelled
uh again you have
you cannot cancel or you cannot modify
an event in kafka what people should
usually have is
a queue of events that allows you to
insert orders
and they will have another log which
canceled orders and you do some
processing after it
where you say
you take the order id and you
update the status probably in a backend
database with cancelled still kafka it's
beautiful because it can also connect
different technologies can connect
databases can connect a file system
with a reliable
scalable and fast streaming mechanism
all right thank you so we have a
question from lucas it's like once my
producer received the new events can i
receive that again somehow how long does
it how long does the producer keeps the
data
okay that's an interesting question
lucas
first of all the producer itself doesn't
have to keep the data for
any time once the data is sent to kafka
it's kafka that holds the data and kafka
can hold the data forever if you set it
up or you can set i want to keep that
only for two hours
so
you can define the time span the life of
your message in kafka depending on what
is your use case
so
um
if your receiver if your consumer reads
the event
and belongs to a consumer group
for kafka the event is done
however you have
options in the consumer to say
you know
i want to go back in history and go back
10 messages and re-read them this is
also an option
so you have always the option if you
know what is the current offset to go
back or go forward in history if needed
um
so the interesting question was from
gabriel where does kafka shine over
other massaging queues i would say for
the fact that doesn't delete messages
that allows multiple consumers to
to be there read the same message
multiple times
so this is a differentiator compared to
i believe rabbit and q
and also the fact that in our days kafka
is almost everywhere it has been proven
to work at
huge scales
with a lot of people
so
i hope this answers your um your
question gabriel
then adam is there a way of maintaining
time order of events from multiple
producers i have cars going okay so the
out of order events is something that
with streaming
data it's a little bit complex because
you know you could have multiple
producers one producer
uh close to your to where kafka sits and
the other producer in australia for
example
and the message
that was produced originally before in
australia arrived to kafka later than
the message
that
is produced closer to kafka
so this kind of
things happen in uh in streaming however
kafka records
the uh timestamp when it received the
message but you can send also the
timestamp from when the the message was
produced
and in uh streaming world you can do the
parsing of the information based on the
time that
kafka detected the event to arrive or
based on when the
the event was produced with the
timestamp that the producer marked
the event so you always have the option
to reorganize events based on the
timestamp of when it was produced rather
than the timestamp or the
offset that is written in kafka
so i think this is the end of the
session because i have to jump to a
panel uh i have to moderate a panel so
i'm really sorry all the questions you
can take on the slack and thank you
thank you francesco for coming today